[Music]
Netflix's post-apocalyptic thriller bird
bugs was its final hits of 2018
but now the streamer has been hit with
serious backlash over some footage
featured in the flick bird bugs featured
plenty of terrifying scenes but the
sequence that has sparked the most
discussion wasn't fictional it was
footage from a real-life tragedy and
that flicks us refused to remove it from
the film it recently came to lights that
the film incorporated actual footage
from a 2013 fiery train crash in the
town of Lac Megantic in Quebec Canada
when an unattended 74 car freight train
transporting crude oil rolled downward
and derailed multiple tank cars exploded
and caught fire resulting in 47 deaths
several other individuals were reported
missing at the time and have since been
presumed dead path of luck Megantic
downtown area was destroyed and the
majority of the downtown buildings that
didn't collapse or catch fire in the
incident were destroyed due to
contamination the scene featuring
footage of the real-life disaster
happens early on in Byrd box and while
the filmmakers only use small bits of
the tragedy lack of Megantic residents
were quick to notice that the clips are
indeed from the deadly accidents Lac
Megantic Mayor Julie Morin told the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation that
she and the townspeople hoped that
Netflix would remove the footage she
explained we find that it's really a
lack of respect to use these images as
fiction and entertainment it's hard
enough for us it's a sudden Cecilia's
images when they are used normally and
respectfully on the news
just imagine to have them used to
fiction as if they were invented Maureen
also noticed that the sci-fi series
travelers also on Netflix had utilized
footage on the Lac Megantic disaster one
of the producers of the show came
forward to apologize and explained that
the images use were sourced through the
stock footage website pond5 she added
that there was quote no intention to
dishonor the tragic events of 2013 in a
statement made to the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation she said that a
team is working to replace the footage
it didn't take long for the people of
Cuba to stand up against Netflix for
utilizing the footage in Byrd box either
Kubek Culture Minister Natalie wah
penned a letter to Netflix his chief
executive officer Reed Hastings
slamming the company for its quote lack
of compassion empathy and solidarity
Netflix says public policy director
Corey Wright has since responded to the
Retton
Planes explaining that a video and
images won't be removed from bird box
according to Bloomberg Wright said in a
letter the use of stock footage is a
widespread and long-standing practice in
the film and television industry as a
result stock images are commonly used
within content on Netflix and on other
services this widespread use prevents us
from making the changes you request
unfinished content going forward we and
the broader industry can do better this
is now the second wave of controversy to
crash over Byrd box as a film stirred up
storms of contention when people began
participating in a dangerous social
media stunt known as the bird box
challenge in which fans would blindfold
themselves and attempt to drive cars
walk through traffic or move down steps
without getting hurt hopefully Netflix
can learn something from this and as a
company said do better moving forward
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]